[Music]
a year ago this week the world health
organization declared covet 19 a
pandemic
while china deserves primary blame for
the devastation the who was a key player
unwilling to blame beijing for its lack
of transparency the who failed in its
primary
responsibility to warn the world of the
pandemic risk
even while the disease forced lockdowns
across china the who hesitated to
declare covet a public health emergency
and when the group's director who was by
the way beijing's candidate for the
position
finally made the declaration he echoed
china's talking points
praising the country while ignoring that
beijing silenced doctors
to regain credibility it's vital that
the who
implement reforms including determining
what went wrong through a timely and
impartial investigation taking the
process from declaring a public health
emergency
out of the hands of bureaucrats
insulating the health emergency program
from political pressure
and matching resources to priorities
absent reform
it will be each nation for itself
should the united states do more to
reform the world health organization
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei